der leider fährt bis zu 80 kilometer pro
stunde und ist insgesamt 35 kilogramm
leicht der rahmen wiegt nur sechs kilo
und stand komplett aus dem 3d drucker
angetrieben per elektromotor der
spaßfaktor ist wirklich sehr sehr hoch
das macht mich und sie ist wahnsinnig
handlich wahrscheinlich natürlich
bedingt durch das geringe gewicht
die harley von bernhard gruber liegt 320
kilogramm
das motorrad ist fast zehnmal leichter
durch zufall hatte er mitbekommen was
seine kollegen auf dem airbus gelände
bei der tochterfirma works kreiert haben
dabei fing alles als schnapsidee an
denn eigentlich ist entwickler nils
grafen luft und raumfahrtingenieur die
idee kam uns eigentlich witzigerweise
auf der weihnachtsfeier da haben kollege
und ich einfach aus privaten interesse
gefragt aber man nicht was in richtung e
bike motorrad machen könnte und es war
dann unser chef so klasse dass er trifft
abgesprungen ist und das würde unser
filmprojekt und hier steht das blatt
weiter entstanden ist er am computer ein
algorithmus hat den light rider
errechnet anhand von daten darüber
welche lasten beim fahren auf ein
motorrad einwirken
wo sitzt wasser motor wie groß ist das
nächste radstand oder was passiert wenn
das motorrad gefahren wird und daraus
hatte sozusagen diese geometrie erstellt
und jedes teil ist im prinzip keine
aufgabe erfüllt hat hat es dann
weggenommen
im 3d drucker werden die rahmenteile
exakt modelliert aus einer patentierten
aluminium legierung aus der luftfahrt
technologie so leicht wie aluminium fast
so stabil wie titan
doch der metallische 3d druck hat noch
grenzen wie die entwickler vor
schwierigkeiten gestellt haben
das sind sogenannte schweißnähte die
sind dadurch gegeben dass wir die
struktur in relativ viele kleine
einzelteile aufteilen mussten da wir
momentan von den druckern her im prinzip
so maximal so einen bauteilen dem
abmarsch gucken können im prinzip diese
aufteilung zu verlegen und wie man das
anderen verfügt das auch sicher ist das
war eine herausforderung
viele designer und kreative haben 3d
druck für sich entdeckt ein stuhl aus
dem drucker kein problem
auch schmuck kann bereits am computer
entworfen und dann gedruckt werden etwas
gewöhnungsbedürftig aber auch die idee
der schuhherstellung funktioniert
start-ups und auch große unternehmen
können ihre ideen so schneller und
günstiger umsetzen
im kreativ labor popup lab in münchen
erklärt johann von herbert die vorteile
des derzeit größten serienmäßigen 3d
druckers die trainiert schneller ein
produkt verbessert außerdem das ist für
mich sehr wichtig sind ihm nicht
zufrieden sind mit dem ergebnis
dann sage ich ihm das exponat schreddern
sie es einfach wäre das werk umfange
hiervon neuen pass haben sie
letztendlich wenn sie haben 35 50 100
euro verloren
die kreativität der mit pfeil auf lassen
von den erkenntnissen beim druck des
ultraleichten leidreiter skeletts
verspricht sich nils grafen auch
fortschritte in der luftfahrttechnik
bringen muss kostet am ende die airline
und am ende den kunden richtig geld
und wenn man einfach erreichen kann dass
durch diese fertigungsmethode in der
druck die teile leichter werden ganz
einfach gesagt bedeutet am ende dass der
kunde weniger zahlen muss und auch das
design sorgt für aufmerksamkeit vor
allem bei den männern auf dem
firmengelände harley fahrer bernhard
gruber hat der light reiter überzeugt es
ist wert jeden fall was für für
kurzstrecken oder wenn man mal kurz in
der arbeit muss gott für solche
anwendungsgebiete bestimmt hervorragend
sonst für leise bestimmt auch nicht für
die nachbarschaft 50.000 euro kostet das
motorrad aus dem 3d drucker 30
vorbestellungen sind schon eingegangen
die straßenzulassung ist in arbeit